first place currently is four seven
and oh the eagles are three seven and
one that
tie could still end up being the thing
that gets them the division or the thing
that keeps them out points bet currently
has the
giants and washington as the
co-favorites at plus
210 the eagles just behind at plus 250
and the cowboys bringing up the rear at
plus
500. who's the team that you would say
right now
especially when we consider that daniel
jones has a hamstring problem yeah
they're not ruling him out yet for this
week but unless he's just going to stand
in the pocket and never try to run he's
going to have a problem with that
hamstring
who would you take in that division
right now well what's they all have
tough
tough uh schedules to end the year
that's the first thing you look at
i i i i guess i'm gonna go with
washington i feel like i've changed my
answer the last
month and a half like every week we've
talked about this
but at least washington's got a defense
a coach who's been to a super bowl
and a quarterback who understands game
management and how to take care of a
football
but geez i wouldn't be surprised with
all these teams here
five games left i mean if all of them go
two and three one and four and we're
sitting here going
holy crap six and ten washington
football team
has won the nfc east and is gonna have a
home playoff game or whoever
because i don't think any of them are
going to get hot here and run the table
i mean
it's not so it's going to be ugly but i
would bet on washington what about you
yeah johnson washington only have one
divisional game left each that's week 17
dallas and philly have two i say
washington and i said weeks ago
if washington would just ride with alex
smith you did say that give them the
best chance
but then but then they then they did and
it didn't work out and they know well
they tried
but that's the thing about the nfc east
you can try and you can fail
but you still have many more
opportunities to get it right because no
one is running away with this thing
four and seven is first place and we've
seen
the giants and washington double their
season win
total in the last two weeks so yeah i
think washington
but any could win
each of them could still pull it off and
that's going to be one of the
interesting issues
and depressing issues of the final five
weeks of the season because one of those
four teams will make the playoffs
and host the five seed in
the uh in the nfc and you know i someone
asked me the other day and i
i still don't believe it i still think
it's better to be
higher on the playoff tree
than lower but will there be a
temptation
to not win a division and be the five
seed so you can
punch your ticket through the division
around more easily
because you're you're going on the road
and playing a bad nfc east team versus
playing at home
against a good wild card team well i i
hear what you're saying if there's a
year to do that this is the year
because you just go well the home field
means nothing who cares right
right but you know just the way it looks
right now who's that
team that's gonna lose games here down
the stretch to do that you know i think
it'll be more about
those teams that are truly wild card
teams right now
maybe they position themselves to you
know of course you want to win and be
the five seed i don't know
but i i don't think like seattle or
green bay are going to lose games down
the stretch all i'm saying
to fall into that five spot but that
five spot is going to be a very valuable
spot whether it's the rams whether it's
the bucks
whether it's uh the 49ers if they can
come up hard on the outside like maybe
they will
that five spot is going to be very very
valuable because that means you get to
go to philly or washington
or the giants right now dallas
in the wild card hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports